citizens of the reject nation we are
here to watch she-hulk episode six
titled daredevil born again what are the
odds yeah they're 150 knew that was
coming
it's not called that what's it called
it's called bts permission to dance
all right a couple of things i wanted to
mention before i say the usual couple
things that i mentioned first off if
you're getting these spam messages i've
blocked so many of them of people saying
we're doing giveaways and contact this
number please do not contact that number
i've blocked many accounts it is not us
we will never do giveaways for any of
our followers you haven't earned it it's
free
we are just not those kind of people to
give something to someone okay buy the
merch
but yes you can get our new citizen king
real rejects exclusive at shop zero
edition dot com for money that's very
real that's the number one way to
support this channel leave a like
don't reply to those messages my shirt
follow koi on tick tock for his uh tik
tok videos because he likes to tick talk
all the time full length throughout your
watch along so you sync up with your own
copy of she-hulk available for super
sexy rejects at our patreon page covers
several shows over there exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included team of prepper think
rub edits it down but the first two
things are the most important and plus
follow koi and also leave a like and
subscribe and patreon or the other more
important stuff first six things the
most important yeah all right i think
that's the intro let's get to the show
[Music]
she's uh
not really my type the court finds in
favor of jennifer walters aka
she-hulk this
isn't over hater
they didn't show the daredevil helmet in
the recap i'm worried uh-oh he's not
he's worried he's not here today dude
we're down to like we're only at 105
likelihood now i don't think he's gonna
ever show up
[Laughter]
dress
that luke made me
in the rehearsal dinner what
oh my god
[Music]
you're going to look hot as shulky yes i
love that name
shulker first use of shulky that's fine
it's just a divorce case it's gonna give
me the opportunity to work so much
closer with miss mallory
yes it's a self-contained wedding
episode and if you think this is
happening at an inconvenient time in the
season you're right cause that's how
weddings always are
you just you just made me feel okay with
daredevil not being
problem solved
crisis averted
oh
everything about you is just working
thank you heather you really took that
toned up for the big day workout plan
seriously yeah yeah girl your ass looks
crazy right now
incredible you're gonna steal the
spotlight from the wedding i don't want
you to be all hulky at my wedding
promise me jen promise i i promise i
will just show up as regular jen at your
wedding
thank you
[Laughter]
the vfx looked good today yeah they had
time the six weeks
yeah obviously this is the one time i
didn't want to show up as justjet
[Music]
jackson
so all the budget went to that one
sequence and now she's jen just jen no
you're gonna be walking with jonathan
he's gonna be at the ceremony tomorrow
jonathan is literally the best oh
awesome okay
although she's all like insecure when
she's just jen
didn't you say your name was craig
hollis it is but i go by
mr
immortal it's pithier
can you blame me for walking out into
traffic during rush hour and putting an
end to the whole issue right then and
there wait what let me get this straight
are you saying that instead of having a
conversation with your wife
you kill yourself to get out of the
relationship
in my case i do die but only in the
legal sense
the i do i die but
i love this concept
i think this is
the most considerate way to end a
marriage yes absolutely i'm obviously
ending your relationship that is so
messed up thank you so much any sort of
personal growth right now i'm not sure
who i should worry about the window
[Laughter]
that is a hilarious concept what a great
use of character
wowie
you're gonna get sued for that man i
know this property tim they have your
information actually i'm the head of a
new department at glk h which is like
one of the most prestigious law firms in
the country as you saw i now have super
powers uh which is nuts no i didn't mean
any i don't want that um like are you
dating a guy what a friend how would you
be a bridesmaid to this person sorry
you'll find someone don't feel bad oh i
don't feel bad that's right you know
what you still have a little bit of time
oh
you better hulk out jeffy yeah right
this is proof of
control hey jen it's so good to see you
i love that you never make any effort at
all
answer to your extremely rude question
is that i happen to be dating a friend
of the groom and he invited me
i am literally just here to celebrate
the love of lulu and her groom that's
all okay that's so sweet
see
not everything is about you jennifer
god she's frustrating yes
talk about the bride
he's absolutely frustrated she is no
madison
she has no wire where you don't think
i am josh
jen
did they give you a plus one for this
because i do not understand the metrics
they used to decide i don't mind see my
plan was to strike up a very normal
conversation with
a beautiful woman stuffing her face with
candy nuts
i'm very good
[Laughter]
you smooth my great reaction
well i never saw a dime for raising
spencer jr alone for all those years
i spent 10 000 on a new orleans jazz
funeral after arnie accidentally
swallowed a cyanide
my friend sent me a link to a video
posted on that site intelligentsia the
one for hateful man babies yup oh good
intelligence the coffee shop
i was thinking
you also forged multiple fake identities
frankly all of these spouses should be
filing criminal charges you are lucky
you're not in prison i will never
understand women
so perfectly cast
oh that guy's great terrible but great
seraphin nice work great casting how
about we split it evenly eight ways call
it a day very fair generous and fair we
were married for 18 years and she was
only with her for three uh because i had
a kid with this fool
why should we be punished for her
mistake oh jeez
[Laughter]
yo yo what's going on my party people is
this [ __ ]
yeah yep hit me with a heavy poor buddy
that'll be an extra five dollars
well what else am i going to do for the
next four hours
boogie
[Music]
dance with josh there's a two dollar
bill in there all drinks are twelve
dollars
i think it's two dollar tips oh that's
good of her
you are gonna be reimbursed for the lake
lawn mausoleum jazz funeral so chic i
love your stuff
you get it sebastian you are going to
receive a sincere apology
with the
meaningful eye contact
thank you
at least 15 seconds
okay and remember everyone what's our
mantra never again never again
is that the absolute best you can do on
eye contact and so amy that's 20 seconds
of eye contact
[Laughter]
this got ugly but i truly did
love each other
[Applause]
unconventional and excellent
you got this nikki
you know everyone is always so
saying about how she-hulk is amazing
uh
they're always saying i just want to be
amazing tonight oh
jennifer
i think you're pretty great
oh no
are you
oh no it's happening
that was a lot of throw ups
yeah let it out babe let it all out
no
oh you
[ __ ]
that was actually surprisingly fun
when that fair and square get over it i
don't get over anything
are you not gonna turn
you know what i can take you like this
[Laughter]
why are you obsessing me i am not
obsessed with you
although it seems like everyone else is
you do not get to ruin everything for me
for something that you don't even want
so now i am forced to prove it so green
up
interesting
just this one time i turned she-hulk
[Music]
oh no i forgot how to do it
[Laughter]
give me a second
[Music]
channel that anger
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we got a wedding fight
oh
a nice musical choice
[Music]
oh my god oh
my goodness oh no are you showing your
11 followers on instagram
where are you going
and i'm taking this
this wedding sucks
oh oh my
i know i promised she sucker-punched me
when i was throwing up like who does
that
she-hulk is at my wedding
i love you so
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
11 years this october what the day after
my son's birthday
hold on you have children you have a
child you have kids malory bookers
that's enough questions okay
wait i gotta look at this what is this
shield
hulking
wait what the hell uh the dress jurassic
park ahaha she was so gross she was 30.
okay
i just copy and pasted what a bunch of
guys have actually said to me on the
internet
accepted
friends with bros
intelligentsia's actual bad group and
like
aren't they i only know the coffee shop
what is this mal how do we kill sheila
this is dark jen is better off just
let her live her life
fine
it's called intelligence
but mallory said not to tell you because
you know she said it would just make you
feel bad and we should protect your
headspace and let you live your life but
i mean you know obviously i didn't do
that
[Laughter]
did we hit yeah oh yeah
okay i'm getting in there
they had fries at the wedding best
wedding ever
no
yeah see
[Music]
were those daredevils hands
confirmed daredevil shrunk down and is
inside each one of those syringes
yeah i've heard of intelligentsia i i
could have sworn
i have you guys said the coffee shop
their stuff is all around these parts of
l.a man overpriced but delicious like
aren't they like a group of villains or
something it depends on what you think
of their prices intelligentsia is a
well-worn concept i'm looking for shoes
yeah that's right i learned to vibrate
let's actually have easter eggs
not going to leave halfway again taking
pics at the wedding oh damn
what the bride
get those veneers fixed for the content
20-second eye contact
look happy to sweat look at my dude
who said that though
turns out it wasn't the team
after four episodes that was the case if
it was a leak i'm inclined to believe it
that's how it works they owe us the
thing they didn't promise you guys have
not been delivering on a lot of your
leaks
it's almost marvel's planting crappy
leaks out there to dilute someone out
there making up facts son of a [ __ ] all
right let's talk about it everyone let's
have a good time
well coy learns what intelligence he is
teaching
all right guys listen i got some
i got some opinions about this episode
that i think might be
controversial
but before that koi who's on the team of
intelligentsia i said they were a group
damn it
the koi egghead which is funny because
nicholas cage wants to play him the one
i think is going to be relevant the
leader which is tim blake nelson who is
coming back the leader's not like always
a member according to this but i think
they're gonna use this this i picked
this format of team because i do think
leaders coming back especially since
they just revealed him as the villain of
captain america four uh modoc we know
we're getting an ant-man and then uh mad
thinker i don't know because it's kind
of redundant with uh you know egghead
and leader uh mole man i think they're
gonna say that for fantastic four uh mr
sinister red ghost one of my personal
favorites trapster aka pace pot pete
someone i said was going to be in the
koi's comic corner video one of my
all-time favorite d plus less villains
pace pop pete my boy trapster you also
said modoc would be in there i'm
championing for it you want modoc i
think they're going to
introduce your appearance corey stole
let's go he's coming so those are those
are the main members also delicious
coffee
and delicious coffee doctor doom
sometimes has been in there too and like
yeah sometimes they have like bigger
villains doctor who is usually a villain
of intelligence yeah that's how they're
introducing that's it doctor doom
confirmed
he's gonna be [ __ ] posting and then
they'll find him when they're really
looking for somebody
i'm on a message
and he's writing in all caps
[Music]
i will track down your ip address
didn't the leader use a computer in an
incredible hulk like wasn't there like
some sort of like mystery game a lot of
characters who have used a computer
the 2000
year 2000. i'm saying what ties it all
together is leader uses the computer
look it's not just circle and arrow
intelligence the important part
is that the great lakes avengers are
coming the great lakes adventures this
is what this really is setting up
like i completely forgot i thought his
name was greg and i've failed this city
but craig hollis uh i twice this episode
guys midnight's hard for me uh but but
mr immortal in the comic books is a
great lake avenger which we looked up
and uh i'm so excited this is my new
favorite marvel like i i honestly think
great like avengers might come because
they've teased other things in she-hulk
that like lead
towards great like avengers that'd be
like a really maybe we don't get west
coast maybe we get great lakes avengers
dude hawkeye season two all about him
training the new team that's so true
all right guys
here's my controversial opinion okay
this is my favorite episode of the
season so far oh wow that's because
you're engaged
beyond that
like really beyond that i feel like this
show this episode was kind of this was
hitting all the marks for me yeah and i
mean it was it was funny
that the way they dealt with the law of
superheroes was like oh you're actually
doing it it's super it was weird that
she hulk wasn't involved with it but
yeah but they were actually doing
superhero law division it had a lot of
that bless you thank you the lord jesus
bless you
and uh it had a lot of the you know the
feminine comedy qualities that i thought
were really clicking uh the fight
between titania and chihok while not
like oh really well choreographed and
stuff there was something kind of
surprising about the punch that titania
delivered to jen when she was like that
was the first action moment i was like
oh whoa that was actually uh that
actually hit a little bit yeah i just
thought it was actually really funny it
was doing all the qualities
that i've been enjoying about the show
so far and um i i really i just liked
everything about this particular episode
and and the fact that they actually did
some real law [ __ ] with what's it like
dealing with a superhero in the law like
dealing with a person with superpowers
the thing we've wanted the thing they
wanted they actually did it's just
jennifer walters was not leading that
and she wasn't in the fight we wanted
she wasn't the last player she wanted
and there was no daredevil
i mean my favorite episode favorite
episode so far all right until daredevil
because obviously yeah for me this one
really clicked and uh i i thought the
vfx looked fine this time around
and so yeah
it's uh i think my third favorite um
like for me one and two uh two than one
this uh i i wasn't in love with the
donnie blaze episode and and last week
was fun but it definitely like left some
humor lacking and i do think the cgi
from last week affected me a decent
amount uh whereas this week the the and
this is a weird thing to say but like
the skin texture looked the best it's
had and it has weight to it it didn't
feel weightless it didn't feel like she
was like out of space it felt like the
skin was around a person like there was
an actual hulk i believe she was in the
room with him and that was the first
time i've ever actually felt that and
outside of the sunshine yeah yeah
exactly when she like goes to greet the
women out there i was like oh i really
believe that i love that like eye
contact that we felt and i was like
that's a person like i felt like that
was a hulk exactly i really enjoyed that
the first suit we saw was the sundress i
thought that was really adorable i think
that i cannot get over how just
impossibly endearing tatiana maslany is
uh that that sound we all lost our minds
for was like such a simple beat but it's
just she's so charming i i like want
jennifer walters in and we had this
recently with uh simulu and chongqi but
like there's a certain charm where i'm
like i can't wait to see them interact
with these characters i already know and
love and now jennifer walters is right
there with chung chi for me where i'm
like i need the avengers i need i need
to see them interact in a dynamic
flute vodka no i agree i enjoyed this
very very much i don't know exactly
where i would rank it but uh i thought
it yeah fired on all the cylinders i've
been hoping
not a virgo no boy
no no no no sadly
i have no one over here like i don't
like ranking things because everything's
different
i have two minds about this
episode ends i'm like where would i put
that exactly
higher or lower oh don't even get me
started uh but yeah no this i would
agree had the each each like flavor i've
been hoping for and it also brought nice
character beats along with it like i
really liked mallory and nikki working
together and at first it seems like oh
maybe they're kind of clashing but no by
the end of it they're like a total dream
team and that goes to further enhance
what's going on with mr immortal and all
that other stuff and yeah you get an
actual situation that is both funny but
then also has to get worked out in a
sort of like i think having just eight
or nine like a bunch of wives in there
really makes you have to sit down and go
how do we solve this for everybody
because of course they would start
asking all these very reasonable
questions about well why do you get the
equal amount that i did for this and
that uh so yeah it felt like it
reflected the real life chaos and then
of course like her friend inviting her
to her wedding soberly being like no
just bring jen and then the
subconscious you know clear adoration
coming out when she's drunk later and
two even titania like even though they
she's an influencer in this iteration
not like a wrestler i liked that there
was almost that wrestler kayfabe quality
where she's like look just let me have
this you don't even want what you have
and i you know you have to work for any
like as much as she is like an annoying
character i thought that was kind of a
neat beat and then to have them sort of
agree on this fight yeah and you're like
i almost feel like she's having a little
bit of fun and this could almost turn
into bonding if it didn't become so
embarrassing and titania and shield have
been friends like they don't often but
like it does happen where they have to
team up like any villain hero duo but i
i saw a little that here and i liked
that well i thought like titania showing
up
and how it was really just i like the
compounding effect of how this whole
weekend getaway or wednesday thursday
get away just kept being a compounding
effect of stress annoyances and
frustrations for her
where she could let it out with being
she-hulk and getting into a fight like
it felt she-hulk to me so and and with
titania
um you know actually showing how she can
manipulate her way through a situation
where other people are not seeing
through the veil at all that she's just
doing this to irk her i found myself
going oh man if she if if if jen gets in
trouble for fighting with titania i hope
people someone saw that titania through
the first much i found myself feeling
that's great
terry silver in this episode i don't
want yeah yeah exactly uh i don't want i
don't i don't want jen to get in trouble
i found myself feeling that i like the
josh guy super charm super charming and
he likes both versions of her
likes exactly likes both versions i
don't trust him
i think he's a villain you think he's
intelligentsia i think he's but he's not
anyone in the comics uh and there's a
lot of josh's how would you know you
didn't know intelligence you know what i
don't know anything i admittedly
admittedly uh 90s hulk comics definitely
a weak spot for me and great lakes
avengers even though deadpool's been a
member not as much of my forte i
apologize maybe josh is a great like
avenger i didn't realize maybe he's just
gonna unmask he's gonna be elixir from
the x-men his name's josh you gotta do
better maybe his name
maybe he's another member of the
wrecking crew maybe he is and i didn't
know maybe he's the leader maybe he's
going to go to the other one kind of
through the groups
victor josh
that way he can
as as part of the wrecking crew he's
part of the wrecking crew he's one of
the villains yeah but he's also one of
the groomsmen for this wedding that she
got invited
it's just a lot of trouble
it's a small town there's like seven of
us really
there's a lot of like networking and
it's a one big little little family and
mr immortal was so funny he was he was
hilarious i thought that concept of a
guy who just is so afraid of
confrontation that he just
this is keeps
recurring living
joke
because i think deep down we can all
relate to that
situation by just dying
quality i thought
he plays like such a good like sociopath
in the way that he's like he seems
constantly so good-natured and yet like
he doesn't actually see anything in
front of him yeah i thought it was
hilarious the ascot was a great touch
like his wardrobe and everything else
the timeless douchebaggery of him was
delightful he was beautiful yeah i i
think that the supporting characters in
the show have been really great i think
that's one of the things that's keeping
that uh you know that spin city island
feel comedy it feels like a show you'd
want to get a guest star audition for
and it's oh there was also a bit of
intensity to the reveal of oh here's
what intelligentsia actually does on
their message boards and they and they
built up a good mystery intrigue as to
who they really are that's trying to go
after she-hulk but you know when they
are going through the message boards um
i thought that was really i was like oh
this is kind of suspenseful i liked that
reveal the last 30-second reveal i
didn't like i was half joking like the
last 30 seconds wasn't there i would
like this episode about what was wrong
with the last 30 seconds they walked in
front of camera holding the broken
needle like at camera like this is where
you should be looking and then replace
it with a thicker needle like just in
case you don't know we're smarter now
did you get mad at the world in the last
couple days yep okay i'm really tired
they made me feel like it was a thing
that i should have seen closer i could
have just gone without the reveal 30
second shaved off better episode i don't
know that's such like a trophy thing to
me that i don't even notice it i like
noticed it was very sam raimi spider-man
which is not my spider-man i beat it
coy i don't think you guys be here when
daredevil shows up that's the next koi's
comic corner top 15 not my superhero
all right guys i had to go on the what
are the what are the what are they angry
youtubers like the the book the
bordering oh the quartering quarter
recorder
yeah yeah all right
about all of our sponsors spikes on the
internet yeah yeah and that dude that
people are always tagging they're like
you know this guy i'm like who's this
guy he's always like yelling at stuff
tyrone
it is a very uh
don't i don't know which era of sci-fi
heart 90s 2000 whatever you want we're
gonna pan through the screen to the real
sinister backstory behind i don't know i
thought it was a fun i i liked that they
made the posts themselves feel real
enough that you're like ooh this seems
like an unsavory place to spend time
with normal people posting whatever also
here's the secret shadowy labyrinth i
suppose titania well what about when
they panted daredevil's helmet
well they watched themselves very
similar they didn't go like bad noodle
broke we're the guys that sent it good
needle better we smart now strong it's
called visual storytelling show don't
tell god they should like three times
they were like tracking tracking
tracking put it down new needle but
what's is it would you rather seen the
scientist's face like the needle drives
home the horry aspect
like put it down
it goes to show you that oh no this
isn't just a bunch of dudes on a message
aboard this [ __ ] is real this is what
happens is you see how much i can
dislike silly minutiae i think i love
everything i hate needles i hate
obviously framed needles
yeah you're not gonna ruin dirt you're
not in next week's acceptance
you're gonna ruin daredevil for everyone
i'm just gonna i didn't like the way
they showed his whole body and face in
the frame i didn't need to know that i
don't know why this suits that straight
yellow
not comic accurate not netflix accurate
who needs it netflix is the only
daredevil marvel woke up his suit i'm
not a fan of it guys 31 to 33 year old
koi likes stuff 34 to 37 year old koi
hates stuff yeah dude
energy first show after my birthday now
i don't like stuff
i'm edgy now
guys it's 90s koi i work for image and
i'm edgy and i have a lot of spikes and
pouches
now did you do that work for an image
and then i was 2 in the 90s
bikes and couches full of diapers
could have had it done man
that's true rob retroactively use cables
time slip by two and hire me at two
years old well i'm sorry i didn't like
the episode i did my third favorite i
just didn't like the needle it would
have been my second favorite i feel like
i'm going to really fix it
without being your whole opinion that's
it all i had to say
didn't talk about the cgi being better
didn't talk about the comedy working
didn't talk about the guest stars
you talk about the references you said
something and i'm i hate you now
and i think that's your whole opinion
and this show isn't live so you're going
to edit out all the nice things it hates
everything just editing out the niceties
i feel like yeah now i'm going to leave
a comment that says coy usually hates
everything yep that's me post birthday i
don't know you always and uh never yeah
i hate her yes the sith dealing
absolutely over here just being real mad
everything is an absolute decline
there's no gray to the way you discuss
things at all episode seven eight and
nine just rage uh but yeah i mean
there's not too much to talk about guys
i mean it was fun
as much as my favorite episode of this
so far it's favorite in terms of
enjoyment it's not that marvel much of
an episode but it's in terms of
enjoyment like no this hits me and
anything like relationship wise has
always really hit with me and the whole
thing about like yo we're doing a
wedding at this point because weddings
are inconvenient
that was clever that worked on me that
made me that really actually made me go
all right i could go with it
yeah yeah that level of self-awareness
really worked for me and i i honestly
think that there's going to be
characters you can't use in the mcu and
they're using them really cleverly like
this this use of mr immortal was genius
like that and that's not a character i
don't think we're getting that take on
him anywhere else that it's been wasted
you really didn't notice any other
easter eggs there was a computer screen
uh and i really was trying to figure out
if there was something about where the
geography was of what they were looking
at but i couldn't figure it out where's
the computer screen what uh the one
before where it said like chesty
she-hulk or whatever
that intelligence before that the the
one that was that they clicked on to get
to that there's got to be a house right
now yeah so right back another like 25
seconds let's go through and read all
the posts so it's the one when we see it
normal before they click through i was
trying to get the map on the left
okay
i'm sick gotcha
so we can see where all the posters are
posted okay see on the left see the top
10 best travel destinations i was trying
to figure out if that was anything
cooksville but like i can't think of
anywhere near cooksville that would be
relevant
[ __ ] she-hulk
dude they're recreating famous artists
like there's no like i looked i this
popped up three times and i kept being
like there must be something and then i
don't think there is what's her icon her
icon looks like frogman
oh my god mallory's frogman
i think confirmed oh
frogman confirmed frog woman i think
he's wearing yellow right now there are
yellow accents on on frog i actually
think what's his name's frogman the ted
dude the date she went on oh yeah yeah
i really i really like the development
of mountains their friendships
i really like the development of it i
love the comedy line when she does leave
the voicemail after such like a tense
moment of like don't don't do this it
was like i was really involved in the
tension in it
i thought this had a really good grip on
comedy and tension and build
that's right man and they used the
jurassic park uh dennis nedry
that's a true easter egg for you guys
now is it ted the guy the guy that was
the date that came back for the
courtroom what's his name
the smarmy guy that called her a
specimen
cancel she-hulk i love it yeah i know
you're talking i think so
yeah i think yeah
miracle workers uh oh that could be
that's that's my new theory i could see
that
don't worry we're gonna we're gonna
break this whole thing down for you guys
when you a hoax but you still don't i'm
just yeah
i guarantee this is from week one of the
show airing like they probably grabbed
these feels real damn
yeah these are
wants equality still wants you to
hulk needs to die this is like the
riddler yeah i know
it could be live streaming next week
it's the leader he uses the computer
he'll live stream next week on his
computer he's later used to computers
[Laughter]
never did anything that would drew from
the entirety of the earth's internet
database or anything like that touched a
computer no way tony stark he just
always had holographic you know uh he
was always minority reporting
i gotta say those fries look they look
so good they were the right amount of
moist and crisp
all right what's on this computer gamma
range up top no easter egg i could find
the macro blood was interesting cause i
thought it might be comparing to hulk
but i couldn't find anything that
compared the two and there's no label
for bruce banner it went by really fast
but i was trying to assess it all
because i was trying to live up to my
couldn't remember craig was the guy that
was already mr invincible uh but yeah i
couldn't find any comparative like data
that would say like names at the bottom
you know eric eric voss will he will
i'll watch his uh he's not going to
though it's going to be jessica
who's going to do it oh
dude she'll find it she'll find it but
but i couldn't
well then the username is hulk king so
is it that that old man king hulk behind
maestro yeah his maestro maestro from
the future he's got koi for an hour and
a half so i'm just like bleeding out his
time
bleeding out
but like yeah looked at all these
screens when they were playing and i
could not like there's mana on the top
right which is what you know aquaman
jason mama always talks about without
spiritual mrna my friend oh is it mrna
it's a meta it's a type of dna right
okay one two three four five needles
seven seconds of that goddamn deal and
then they put it out again and then they
come on could have just been the one
that was excessive
oh and it's it's like perforated
again
but they're an evil shadowy organization
it's a classic evil shadowy organization
i can't believe you hate the episode
just because of that i can't believe it
knocked it down a whole slide i gotta
remember to put that at the top of this
review coy hates the episode i will
never include an insert shot of a
chekhov's gun in anything i i try and
show you you can include one not seven
seconds and then one and then another
one john cause you're better than that
all right try to be
thank you john you're well checking
something for us yes it's up okay so up
so good so money baby you're so money
all right guys well we're done with this
video coy you really brought the room
down too well you know what i said one
night i see everybody wants me to be
happy all the time as soon as i'm not
this is what happens you have one off
day i'm okay with you being negative if
it's in agreeance with oh okay we're all
negative but but if you love something
no i don't know what don's well but if i
get in competitions okay if your
negativity is
not balanced is not the same as mine
then i feel like you're toxic because
i'm like a b-plus and you're like i
wanted this be an a i'm like this is
that that negative is is really bringing
it down that that temperature
it's it's really uh this is affecting my
mood sorry about taking it personally
and um i can't trust you on any more
opinions moving forward no more comments
this is how it gets more toys comic
mislead you know what i was trying to do
26 through 50 like the comments
misinformation nope guys just more
negative videos
raging in the corner of my own comic
corner dude do some hate watch reactions
just me watching catwoman play
basketball yeah
all right guys we're done follow koi on
tik tok where he's constantly ranting
about things in vogue culture
and uh follow john on tick tock
talking all the time
culture that's right it's true that's
all the tick tocks any time he's mad at
someone he compares them to hitler i do
everyone's like it's a real easy
touchstone a lot of people out there
like hitler
it's right there it's right there he's a
slightly bad person he's just there
equivalent because that's
yeah deadpool 2 deleted scene killed
baby hitler they actually had to go back
in time and there's there's a the end of
the credits was supposed to be deadpool
looking down at baby hitler and going
like can i do this and there's this
whole series of cut scenes with him like
trying to figure out the moral fixation
of killing business i really should have
kept it
that is funny bring it back real good
it's just a little adolph and a little
bassinet and he goes like oh it's genius
i'll show you
all right guys well this is really done
and we really dragged out what should
have been a 10 minute talking
four minutes
[Music]